[Music]
this is just an intro it's just an intro
the guest is coming on soon so quit
bitching we're gonna start the show
right after this intro you're listening
to inside you with Michael Rosenbaum if
you're looking at me in a wide shot
you're gonna see tons of papers around
there's a lot of stuff going on I hope
you're having a good week I know it's
just been one day in the week
yesterday that was Monday but you know I
just you know in terms of anxiety and
stuff I find that if I don't stick to
that routine man flipping out I notice
it'll short-tempered I'm not I'm a
little not patient so all I say is hey
you know I didn't work out three days in
a row I just think stack up I got to
stop and say no go work out you release
some steam do it I'm just saying
news every day man I know you guys are
going to like what is going on here man
but I get frustrated cuz every day it's
something different I almost want them
to give us the news just on Fridays give
us news cuz every day okay a mask don't
wear a mask
wear a mask okay now the antibodies you
get the test that will help and now we
don't know they're not sure don't get
the test so it's almost like every day
it's changing and like you know I think
that's where the most anxiety comes from
is everybody's just like what are we
what are we doing well it's sort of in
limbo [ __ ] limbo rush limbo oh sorry
here we are another episode I'm glad
you're sticking around and listen to the
episode by the way you know the podcast
definitely I think everybody who has a
podcast is taking a little chunk because
I think people aren't commuting as much
to work and doing whatever and so you
know you're knows how Atlanta and have
as many as listeners in fact last week's
episode Bob Odenkirk holy [ __ ] man I was
just sensational and I hope people come
around to listening to I know everyone's
got their lives and they're busy and um
you know and I respect it and I'm I
appreciate you guys for tuning in every
week and a big shout out to my patrons
who tell them all that
but there's a wave to you patrons you
guys are I don't know you're just really
special and you really help to show more
than you could possibly imagine so I
love uh when i refresh and you see a
patron I do like a refresh in the
morning and refresh at night and you see
new patrons you're like oh my gosh and
if you don't know what patreon is it's
just uh you go to patreon.com/scishow up
in online store for inside do you stuff
and what else there's also my band stuff
left on Laurel as of now July 2nd we're
still planning on doing the live podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
live in Austin at the north door with
Zach Levi from Shazam but uh just stick
around and we'll find out we're kind of
everyday again we're waiting to see what
happens I've been trying to FaceTime a
grandma as much as possible she's alone
I can't imagine what it's like for her
91 years old she's such a good woman who
loved her so much we were trying to do a
house party thing or a house party
everybody it's like another zoom thing
she was she couldn't get it to come when
she was muting herself she was like kept
turning herself around you know with the
little switches just I was like only
[ __ ] man and and my uncle can't go over
there to help her really exciting
[Music]
beverly d'angelo is my guest this week
she is by the way before I say that make
sure if you will I know you guys are
listening um subscribe write a review
I've got to say it podcast the at the
handles at inside podcast on
I think Instagram and Facebook and at
insta pod inside of your pod [ __ ]
sorry Twitter I've been doing a lot of
Instagram lives I hope you're enjoying
that look for me again and patreon I'll
probably do another private you to live
with you live but beverly d'angelo she's
been on the show before she's such an
eccentric lady and so she's just full of
life and
so much experience she has a story about
everything and she's one of those fiery
ladies that could just hug you and then
smack you if she needs to do it she's
tough she's she's lovely and brilliant
and it's an honor to have her on the
podcast again I know she's listening
wasn't easy edit Ryan really had to work
on this Bev I love Beverly D'Angelo and
you will too again but this is uh this
is this is a lot of fun
let's get inside beverly d'angelo it's
my point of view you're listening to
inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
I took you out to dinner a couple weeks
ago yes you did and you said nobody asks
me to go - nobody does now what is that
well that's a lie I just went back there
with Rufus Wainwright yeah my dear he's
a very talented guy you love I love him
what's so great about him besides music
in his brilliance as a person because he
is as open as a person and as responsive
as a person as the songs that he sings
to represent that he's the real deal
how many times have you see him in
concert five do you cry this concert we
see now hey Ron could you get me a
bottle of that water you have a water
right there what about the diet coke oh
yeah I don't have any coke at all I'm
trying you know I'm trying to chai I'm
even I don't even eat artificial
sweeteners anymore it's the key to my
everlasting beauty it's yeah it's
uncanny but it is you do look great
you've been working on yourself though
it's not like you can just do that and
then they not work yeah no no no I'm
enjoy but also you know I experienced
this incredible freedom because here's
here two keys one is I spent 18 years
getting up every morning at 6:30
basically and either picking up my kids
to school and making arrangements for it
and kind of fitting a life in in between
the time like if they were staying with
their dad or something like that and my
life was really being of service so you
were a mom pretty free I mean you worked
but for 18 years you mostly work like a
mom yeah so that cuts out on a lot of
stress you know it's a different kind of
when you're when you're stressed from
being of service to someone when you're
when your priority is love you know yeah
it looks like it doesn't age you as much
but that's purpose purpose purpose for
but but what happened is so so now
they're launched what and it's launched
and it's a good launch there's they're
stable they're good kids were you
worried that they were
gonna be stable you know movie star kids
yeah well I didn't educate him in
Hollywood I didn't infiltrate them with
Hollywood it was the private schools
though they went to private schools yes
but out of town
Northridge down in America the people
knew who they were you know from a very
young age I explained to them that that
there were people whose goal in life was
to let them know how well they knew
their dad and that it was really
important to understand the difference
between people being attracted to Fame
and getting to know you and I'm a great
[ __ ] detector and I guided their
banette and they're good at it well it's
it's tough enough having you know like I
had parents who weren't famous you know
and there was a still a lot of
dysfunction so you know how could there
not be dysfunction you know it's beverly
d'angelo heartthrob actress in Al Pacino
how does that not like well I cut all
that stuff out when I became a mom
though I didn't I never I didn't live in
my life as a famous person how do you do
that I didn't work a lot on purpose yeah
it was always how long and and how close
am I gonna be do you love work I love
inspiration I love feeling inspired I
seek it I am an advocate of doing
whatever it takes to find your
inspiration point I know what mine is
you know mine is yearning - being in the
yearning you know that's when this stuff
comes out of me the writing the desire
was when I have a desire to express you
know and Hollywood never afforded me a
lot of those opportunities you know and
why is I do think you just you're lucky
it's kind of the roll the dice it's like
you know what am i what are they gonna
give me a lot of it had to do with
vacation because when I did Coal Miner's
Daughter I it was really an ignited for
Golden Globes really is really an acting
Patsy Cline black hair voice singing you
know
that kind of stuff but then I did
vacation and it really the way that I
look I don't look Italian I don't look
dark
I look pretty much like the girl next
door kind of her I think I was that milf
they invented that word right you know
and I think Lauren well I would like a
grand mil or whatever it is no but but
in any way um and I and and and also you
know that was like mid-80s that was like
you know the beginning of this concept
of you know franchises and stuff like
that and so I think that that that that
that person that rests so easily in the
public's mind you know the public people
turned into the people that we're in the
studio's there were students and law
students and all that so I didn't know I
think that had something to do with that
I do note I can always tell when
somebody is a vacation fan I can always
tell by the way they react the things I
say if they're surprised or askance or
whatever I can I can just tell how they
react did you fight it for a long time
were you like hey this is great I have a
lot of success no I that's where the
lack of ambition comes in that's where I
just I moved to Italy in 81 then I moved
to Ireland in 84 I basically lived
outside of Hollywood to get away from
that it wasn't to get away from it but I
certainly you said did I fight it and
I'm saying not only did I know the
answer is no I did not fight it I moved
you moved I left was yeah I were a great
agents and all that kind of stuff cuz
you were kind of a triple threat right I
suppose so but I didn't I didn't I
didn't pursue it Michael not not
ardently I'm gonna go back to that
dinner we had two weeks ago pump it up
patch a because che runs the joint and I
love going there I'm so great I mean it
will get up and actually where we sat
was good because I was worried about the
acoustics there and sitting outside I
went back with Rufus and his foster and
you and Apache and we sat in the same
place so you said no one ever asks me to
dinner
well no I don't get asked that a lot
what dates I don't cars wasn't a date
I've known you forever I asked
but I'm not a dater but-but-but how does
someone not want to take beverly
d'angelo on a date you don't put
yourself out there enough just just just
that just that phrase disgust me what
yourself yeah yeah what am I supposed to
say you don't try hard enough that well
but what why should I try how old men
supposed to know you're available how
are they supposed to see you in this
pocket
guys listen I know I'm not an
instagramer looking you're a hopeless
romantic you know IIIi someone has to
find me that's what I came at this point
well I know but have we ever tried
anything like that no I know I some has
fired me well you've had moments you've
had like but yes you told me about some
you call them dry spells where you're
like you know what I'm busy I'm doing my
thing now of celibacy in me yeah yeah
and that was a while that was like four
months excuse me it was a while it was a
while but then there's a woman I'm sure
women think this cuz guys always think
if there's a woman ever think and you're
not like this I know just from knowing
you you're not like this you're not I'm
very atypical but don't you feel like I
just want to kind of get effed um yes
yeah but we call it we say break me off
break me break me off I've never heard
that just right it's more of a different
race you'll break me off break me off so
you do think those things I do so do you
ever have your friends try to hook you
up like find me someone that's cool some
of they hang out with something I could
listen to records to someone I could
just be myself I can just start singing
around the house looking exactly and
does it happen every once know they say
meet this guy Richard he's fantastic
I've had some Richards I've had some
setups never Hut work do they you ever
noticed that they never work and it's
always when a woman says you have to
meet my friendly
honey run because they're never as
pretty as the friend who sets them up
with me well I don't think it's about
being pretty for me I don't I'll or
pretty no I find that rather
intimidating well I'm not saying being
attracted to them oh I need to be
attractive but I'm saying that my my
triggers for for for attraction don't
necessarily lie with the physical thing
what's the attraction intellect humor
humor is that number one if some smart
smart smart so number one smarts no
humor wit he's much too fast but you've
you've gone out with you've had sex with
people that aren't that smart or that
witty or that funny that's not true
have you ever gone out with someone who
just wasn't funny no really I could name
one person who I won't say it say it
initials um it's a Brian with rhymes
with his that thought pisher oh that was
Carrie that was carries idea that wasn't
even my idea that's what I'm saying
people hook you up and yeah whatever it
didn't work out with this person you
just wanted to be sisters in real life
well you were sisters I know but like we
were you know but she hooked you up with
this person and that person was funny he
was funny he was funny
yes i dot was fine see you said his name
he put me in his book he did yeah what'd
he say about you he said that all this
stuff and he said things like you know
as my sister said how could I be
born-again Christian I was dating
Beverly D'Angelo but that's kind of a
stab and well took god I'd SIA but
anyway no but anyway no but he said that
that the wonderful thing was that I I
made him aware of what he really wanted
I think I am a transitional but even
then he got married so that's what I
don't want now I see saying you're the
woman who is what I don't know I'm a
good transition but I men look at me for
transitions like I've held the hands of
dying people I've transitioned a person
into Parenthood I've transitioned people
into the so
many men that I've been with have found
the perfect person after me but if you
think about it everybody's like that so
if they find one person everything
before then was searching for the right
one yeah but why am I always the person
that's right before the right way well
I'm always the guy that I why am I the
guy who they're always like so and so we
got to fire that guy you know what we
only have to date let's hire Rosenbaum
he's good he'll help because I I'm on
I'm always on this track of like if
nothing else it's a profound friendship
because the men that I like are people
that I want to know they're people that
I like I actually like that who's the
last person you liked that you said I'd
like this guy I want I'm enjoying him
I'm sleeping with him this is fun he's
funny he's someone I didn't sleep with
someone oh do I know this person now I
don't know do I know of this first yeah
was it years ago yeah and so you never
slept
you had sort of a emotional thing mm-hmm
you kind of talked to you yeah that was
it yeah but never had sex not really
okay so I just find it I find it tough
because I think you're so talented and
so pretty inside out so smart I gotta
tell you something I was in see again
I'm all about the yearning in fact I
sought someone out because I knew he
would inspire me to do something that I
really needed to be doing anyway I got
like basically a book out of this guy
and these and songs and stuff you're
writing a book a and your song book of
erotica but anyway and and and I you
know cuz I can't tell anybody about it
I'm too embarrassed but I did say to
this one guy friend in New York a
younger man the 36 year old I talked
about him but anyway I said you know I
had this fantasy that I'll is that you
and me that was probably you I have this
fantasy that uh oh did I not bring my
phone after you have your phone in there
I don't and I I was late getting here
because I needed to find my phone that's
not any way to my friend I said I have
this fantasy that I'll send him like the
first section of my book and and he'll
and a fall in love with me and and and
he said he said a man will never do that
he's that a man will never go I'm not
really into her but wow that book she's
writing [ __ ] it now on there he said men
don't do that they they don't do that
they don't care if you're a talented or
creative or madly ingenious unless
unless what you try to turn it off I
gotta find my phone I just want to see
if I hear it
it is in your purse where is it hello
yeah this is bizarre oh okay
alright turn it off I'm trying to this
episode is brought to you by magic spoon
look at this
ah yeah I'm holding up a box right now
you can't see it if you're just
listening it's such a beautiful box you
know growing up everybody I know would
always have these cereals in the morning
that were just they were delicious but
boy were they bad for you right and
that's what kind of why as an adult
you're like you know I'm gonna want you
to eat I got it
we can't go we can't have that you
missed those days where you could tap in
a nice box of uh well don't say any
names but you can do that now but you'll
still have that taste the tasty
breakfast treat the cereal but you won't
have the crap that's in it I'm looking
at a box right here of magic spoon grain
free cereal zero grams three grams of
net carbs 11 grams of protein four
flavors
we got blueberry frosted cocoa tastes
amazing
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb and GMO free you
can tell all your friends even those
people who don't believe in that stuff
which I do
religiously it helps go to magic spoon
calm slash IOU grab a variety pack and
try it today and be sure to use our
promo code I owe you a check out to get
free shipping and magic spoon is so
confident in their product is backed
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason you could send it to me No if
you don't like it for any reason they'll
uh they'll refund your money no
questions asked magic spoon dot-com
slash
IOU and use the code I owe you for free
shipping we think magic spoon for
sponsoring the podcast inside of you is
brought to you by expressvpn now we all
know expressvpn protects your privacy
and security online
you know that but there's there's
something else you might want to know
you can also use expressvpn to unlock
movies and shows that are not available
here like only available in other
countries so now that many of us are
stuck at home it's only a matter of time
until we run out of what to watch on
Netflix so this whole week I've been
using expressvpn to binge Doctor Who UK
Netflix it's simple to do I just fire up
expressvpn the app I change my location
to the UK i refresh Netflix I'm done
that's it but it's not just Netflix
expressvpn works with any streaming
service Hulu BBC iPlayer YouTube you
name it if you visit my special link
right now guys at expressvpn dot-com
/aou you can get an extra three months
of expressvpn or free support the show
watch what you want and protect yourself
with expressvpn at expressvpn dot-com
slash I owe you okay it's off anyway
yeah and he said it doesn't matter and
and you know it's true and I mean my
life has always been about their
creative I'm not kidding and I know it
doesn't look like that in a career or
anything and all the things I've walked
with well recording great on everything
I've walked away from but it's the truth
I I always I have a go-to it's like my
neuro-pathways
if you feel something and it doesn't get
an immediate response from somebody then
you got to write it out you got to sing
it out you got a dance that you got to
work it out I mean I'm a big subliminal
person and so that doesn't allow me to
interact in a way like traditional women
interact with men but when you say the
thing about the book men aren't gonna
like it care about a girl don't care
it's not good how about a man isn't in
this illustrate who just as there's men
who just like one a date like their
woman's brilliance is is an attraction
and on top of it I maybe initially shut
out all the girls how about how many
women you see with these guys and
they're like what the [ __ ] and they're
like well he's brilliant he's
you know he wrote something he does he's
not an actor ease I don't know if I
agree with you I don't think there's I
think they're intimidated by it that's
what happened at all intimidated what a
woman who wasn't intimidated I'm
intimidated by women would you be
intimidated by a woman if you went over
to her house and she started kissing you
in mid-sentence and like came on your
leg would you find a game on my life
would you find that intimidating a bit
overwhelming no I don't think so if I
like her why would I fight wait you're
saying if I go win over a woman's house
and if she's aggressive like that
both by now I can understand why an
aggressive woman it depends what we're
talking about here because if it's the
first time we're kind of hooking up it
gets a little aggressive yeah here's
what I suggest
I'm single so my suggestions now thank
the mic mine [ __ ] them right you should
just sit here and do it hey not
self-help calm yeah because to me I
think blind leading the blind
it is bucket yeah to me it's like you
know you kind of want to ease it a woman
yeah and at first it was sexy and subtle
and all these things and then whoa look
out tiger it was like whoa and then it I
mean it was sex and subtle I was caught
me through the sexy and subtle part well
you hang out you kiss you flirt it's
easing your way into it Plan B text you
the song yeah yeah do that oh great
great come in yeah you know what I can
come in for ten minutes but I'm serious
it's gonna be ten what I'm saying is and
then what and then oh I think from me
yeah it all depends but if I have if I
hit if I'm with a woman yeah and we ease
into it and it's nice and sexy and
everything's going right then I I in a
way it gives me confidence and like I'm
comfortable in this sometimes when I'm
attacked I've had attack where all my
guy I think he just bit through my lip
yeah or it's like crazy and I'm like
whoa is that all she's in new [ __ ] maybe
in my mind that's what she's into
I'm not a [ __ ] porn yeah maybe yeah
you know I can't [ __ ] like she probably
thinks I might be able to [ __ ] that's
never been exactly when all I should
worry about just worry about the first
[ __ ] yeah remember I was talking about
that was the first just do you remember
I eat you were worried some with some
guy you were dating a long time ago yeah
you were worried that I don't know I
don't love my body like I should it sees
me maybe what if he doesn't come back
tires and I go yeah let's get past the
first talk yeah not the second yeah yeah
yeah I wrote it down because I thought
it was so funny at first because you
were worried about the second [ __ ] when
you haven't even [ __ ] the guy well yes
that's the one to worry about
first [ __ ] easy not the first I really
think in fact this was used on me by one
of the absolute great loves of my life
owl I'm not gonna tell you the story but
you're gonna try to turn it into a
personality thing all right no I let me
just say this then that in my lifetime I
did experience someone saying hey we're
not gonna do this until we cannot help
it just so hard okay so you just
answered wrong a and B and B okay but
you have to promise me that we'll do
this again right after and
the two hottest lines you can Satan
anybody wait okay here's what
intimidates me about that line one was
great yeah the first time was great yeah
but at 47 years old if someone says hey
we're gonna do this again right now I'm
like right now oh good good good cuz you
know no this the guy has to say it yeah
the guy says it he's like well he's he
must be really into you if he wants to
go a second time right well because what
you're gonna explain at night just a
lowly 47 just a pen something can you
can you do it twice on I can here's the
thing if I'm really into someone I can
but if also I'm really into someone I
can't yeah it doesn't mean I don't like
the print it's just the pheromones it's
whatever it is the chemistry yeah that I
could just keep going after that yeah
but that one I it's not I'm not hiring
yeah what is that interesting yeah I
just like sex therapy yeah I mean this
is what I'm into these days what is it
what I'm into these days is actually and
it's been for a while now I'd say like
propel East a year right I've been very
fascinated by the entanglement of sex
sexual feelings and in the emotional
field and this is because I came of age
sexually in the era of free love I was
out here at 17 and boom you're [ __ ]
everything everything because and I had
a boyfriend too but because it was free
love and so I I didn't I didn't go
through that oh I'm a bad girl boy I'm
gonna be coy or I'm gonna learn how to
seduce it's just I was free free free as
a bird and and I really remain free
until I became it so just before I
became a mom really I'm it was just my
mindset but in most ways although I feel
deeply passionately I kind of go from
like fixation to fixation to fixation to
fixation but anyway my sexuality was
totally enmeshed with my emotional life
it was like if you're if your deepest
emotional truths are here and your
sexuality is here the more you keep
hitting that and getting into it you
know it's gonna get down in there and
then it's gonna get all entangled with
your emotions and I'm very interested
not in the disentanglement but the
awareness of it I you know I have this
pie
and typical me another podcast another
thing I've never brought to fruition but
I interviewed a bunch of people
including this woman who was the
hereditary heir of tantric knowledge
pantry knowledge which is sexual right
and I found her fascinating I found the
way that she became that person
fascinating but also the whole idea of
tantric sex and that actually you know
part part of that is the belief that
that that sex is a path of enlightenment
that if you do it right you're like you
know you get like a bang and I I'm best
neighbor okay okay but yeah I mean but
at the same time if you don't think that
it's intimidating attacking someone
imagine how far this rap goes talk to me
about tantric for a second cuz Ryan you
probably don't know anything about it no
that's why I'm asking and I don't give
you the whole lecture but give me let me
give you some tips oh okay
no let me give you some tips you don't
moan and stuff like that like that yeah
let me give you give me some just the
tip just practical you know what you're
gonna do is you know how like men and
women alike we kind of have this goal
oriented mentality of like you start the
here and then you go race to the finish
line so it's all about building building
building that has a lot to do with
watching porn don't watch point stop
watch I rarely do but you know it's like
we have this mentality as you start here
and then you you know you kind of ease
in and they just start pumping harder
and harder harder in a boom you come
right nope okay yeah so tell me how to
[ __ ] about please tell me how to have
sex with a woman but everyone right now
who's listening is really less because
they want to know some things too why
not improve your sex life why not
improve the way things because yeah well
men we rush it we're like oh my god this
is it you know see I'm guilty er there I
can speed right I can come
right now I mean not literally but you
know on this podcast you know if you
want to but I won't but here's what I
wanted to say okay tips for a good sex
life
okay you must understand that men and
and I'm just speaking to heteros out
there okay okay I could you know I have
that buy thing but I'm just speaking at
it because the other buy thing because
you work because you're a man so let's
just buy okay so let's just keep it to
the men women thank you
okay you must acknowledge that men and
women not only are different but what we
think differently and and it's even been
proven scientifically the synapses are
different between the you know and it's
been the cerebral cortex convinced me I
know that that we think that well number
one embrace that number one embrace that
number one embrace the fact that when
you speak to a woman you're speaking to
someone who's very brain is organized to
listen and to perceive what you want and
to pick up verbal cues and emotional
cues and and women are are highly able
to tune into emotional needs so when
you've got a man who can speak it
emotionally and and and reveal emotional
needs and you've got a woman's attention
how do you do that give me an example
like if I'm let's say we're together I'm
saying things to you like what do you
want let me tell you how to get laid no
no no I'm not saying that I'm saying
because I can tell you right like right
now my mind went to I'm with a woman
let's imagine what she's thinking in
which she wants well number one you
listen you know so for example if you're
going out you know me I can get hyper
detail just saying that you go out to
dinner right you listen
what did she what does she order does
she order soup
- order something crunchy soft means
that be easy with me soft means that
she's got some sadness in their crunchy
means anger so if she goes for the
calamari depends
well that's adventurous
I'd say Calamari's adventurous right I'm
up for okay so you can read a woman more
or read a guy by what they're ordering
no I'm just saying it's listen for a man
- if a man cares about a woman he's he
should really try to listen to her and
respond honestly and then you might not
even want to [ __ ] her you know what I
mean but if you've got a woman who's
like a name a name and mangey maybe then
if you listen to her it'll it'll it'll
cancel out just that lust that you have
for if you really listen so once you're
in the ballpark
and you've you've heard what a woman
you've listened to her and you like her
then I think what you want to do is
respond in some way let her know that
you're listening to her because the
reason bringing those because I guess
what I'm trying to say that's the
foreplay that's where 4/pi starts
foreplay is really listening foreplay
for a woman starts with conversation
well yeah for played for a man starts
with what she's wearing right you know
like you use kind of start your foreplay
thing in your mind you are right you are
right and by the way if it's just about
in general what you're saying is you
know spend some time just talking and
listening and getting that's that's a
big part of it instead of just going
it's just well we haven't gotten to how
you have sex okay because if that what
I'm saying is boys remember that four
play starts in conversation listening
and also it'll save you a bunch of time
because if you really listen to someone
you might go you know what I don't care
too much I want to [ __ ] her
this is 8 the Trail of Tears here and
the same thing for a guy and the same
thing for how many times of you I want
to [ __ ] this guy man they start talking
and talking you're like no yeah
that's happened oh yeah this has
happened with any big movie stars
Michael shut up I'm sorry I went there
ok
I'm just curious like the biggest honky
is coolest sexiest most talented [ __ ]
and you're like they're still talking
that they talked you out of it talked me
out of it and then they tried like now I
try to avoid even saying the word no in
my life I try to avoid it
well what do you say changes subject and
you did distract but let's get Gerald to
it so now you've you've listened and
you've gone you know what I'm aligning
here I'm aligning here with this person
that I'm listening to
so anyway mning to the chase I and
getting to the tantric part you know
what tantric sex is about is that you
sit and you you you don't do anything
you just look at each other whoa just
sit there allows each other you know put
your hand on her heart or her body or
something you just don't do any okay you
don't want to do this in the first time
you have sex or something Wow excuse me
for a second let me just even but that's
why I'm saying that this thing about the
first [ __ ] you do have to get it out of
the way because that some perhaps your
whole point to this get it out of the
last why I was a little aggressive
you're saying so you're also thinking
I'm kind of like a guy that's exactly I
was gonna say you yes my problem no what
he wants
you think the guy does I'm gonna be
aggressive and game awesome gonna
[ __ ] yeah but I'm telling you it's
not I don't know a lot of guys I don't
know but maybe I just don't think that
that maybe there's a happy medium
maybe he says hey you're not gonna have
sex with me if you want to be aggressive
but you say sex I mean yeah yeah that
would mean that a guy would have to say
Bev Bev I don't need that from you that
I don't need I think that guys say that
I don't need that from you they don't
need sex
they said that's here I think I've heard
everything
have a good guys turn down sex for you
from you yeah like you said I'm willing
and the
now yeah really I find that hard to
believe hey did that well maybe was a
big where you aggressive with them yes
so maybe that maybe that whole thing is
there's good reasoning on your side yeah
but what they didn't do was go whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I'm going to be in charge
here so if you if they would have said
maybe they weren't man enough to do that
that's right they could have just
flushed a Matt watch they could have a
hey Beth Beth whoa whoa stop for a
second listen you're [ __ ] hot I want
to jump your bones I just we gotta take
it slow
hi this is kind of like I don't know
it's just not not in that I'd whatever
you'd be cool with that as long as he
said hey take it slow I think for me um
it has to be a fearless man who who who
loves to be loved who would love to try
to be in charge of this so how about
this let me pretend I'm doing hey you
don't need to do that [ __ ] yeah now
you're talking about that's a guy hang
on that's this is a guy a guy channeled
him Payet Beth don't need to do that
[ __ ] okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah get over so it's
still sex he's like yes yeah man just
calm down calm down and then you're like
whoa and then I'm like I'm calm Don
Henley no why does everybody talk about
Don Henley do that well you had sex with
me I didn't have sex with them years ago
you know if you really think I thought
you said it on my last podcast that's
what I said it did you not know okay
Carrie did Carrie did she dated him for
a while that's how we became best friend
that's right
yeah I know that whole story and if you
haven't heard it you give us some of the
other do you know what don't you know
I gotta keep my thing straight now I do
listen you know you talk you you are
self-deprecating I think I tell myself
deprecating well I hate that about
myself well you got it you had it or got
it I got it I was now I lost my thought
to you that's you said our
self-deprecating I think look we all are
and I think that's a defense mechanism
it's like you do have all these great
things but you I think you always are
like oh I'm not acting enough I'm not
doing this enough I don't I'm gonna rush
I think we all do that where we're just
like so hard on ourselves and I think I
need to meet a musician a musician a
good musician inside of you is supported
by better help online counseling this is
one you need to listen to folks
especially in the times times like these
you know I deal with anxiety I deal with
stress I deal with depression
I deal sleeping issues most people do
they don't talk about it that's why I
have the podcasts of people like you
listen to constantly they talk about
their anxieties and things and I hope
that helps people but you know it really
helps people is better help online
counseling it's an affordable way I
think across the country I've gotten
therapy from top therapists or but it
it's expensive and they're not always
right there for you and they're always
you know it's it's a lot but if you're
struggling with the things that I deal
with along with
many others people deal with so many
relationships sleeping anger LGBTQ
matters all these things better online
counseling can help so you connect with
a counselor in a safe private online
environment anything you share is
confidential that goes without saying
all you do is simply fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your needs
and you get matched with the counselor
in less than 24 hours so if you're
freaking out going oh it's gonna take me
months to find somebody no it's not
where they're gonna help you a fast
easily scheduled secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages if for any
reason you're unhappy with your
counselor request a new one at any time
and guess what no additional charge
better help is a truly affordable option
and our listeners get 10% off your first
month with discount code inside go to
better help calm slash inside that's
better
h ELP comm / inside and you know talk to
a therapist online and get help how old
you said you went out with a 36 year old
kindest yeah okay was that fun yeah
would you date another 36 year old or do
you want to have a real serious
relationship someone someone can grow
old with i I you know honestly I even
thought that probably the best person
for me would either be someone who's
married so I don't have to deal with any
of that or even unable in some way
disabled unable unable unable what I
will do one able to be devoured by me
because when I'm in the yearning when
I'm in the desire that's when all my
stuff comes out and I become brilliant
and I have to finish my show I have to
get that thing performed you know I've
been working on that for a long do you
think how passionate by the way are you
about your career now cuz I mean you
just finished I'm totally I'm totally
passionate about
I'm doing it I'm making and mounting
this show that's unbelievable with video
and and and and soundtrack I just what
is this gonna happen well that's the
thing I just I either got to get
somebody to break my heart so I can
finish it or material yeah but also this
is the thing what I find myself doing is
I'm I'm looking to be in that stage of
need and and I find that I'm attracted
to you know things that will put me in
that state of need because it seems to
be the only way that I can create
something as if I want something or
somebody that doesn't want me do you
want to stop the cycle no that's my
point I gave you over so you're telling
me it gets me going so you're not really
sad those things don't work so this is
all just come on I'm not kidding do you
think every great thing came from you
your heartbreak or somehow you get a
yearning yearning not an Harpeth
yearning desire but was ire desire
desire do you want sexual did I just
desire desire desire that's what gets me
to be in that state of desire so you
really don't need someone you really
deep down no I do I need a guy who make
me to make you feel the desire so you
could use him for when he dumps you
how could he really dump you if you want
him to dump you because I pick someone
who will never get there in the first
place I think deep down you're full of
[ __ ] I think deep down there's something
that you really do want something
meaningful and long I guess you haven't
hurt you haven't hurt but also you have
had great sex you've had a great life
you've had all these great things so
maybe you just want to focus on your
career I don't know you tell me
that was awfully demanding Michael Chaya
said you liked it you're being in charge
of me I'm being in charge
being in charge ooh yes I want yes I
want to keep doing what I'm doing with
my eyes on the prize of full expression
of what it's meant to be alive
my path it's good stuff that I must
share that I want to share where are you
you're happiest honestly when do you
feel I'm happy at this moment when I'm
in that state of desire does won't give
you that the feeling working on my show
does show but like working and
insatiable that didn't give you any kind
of the first episode it did because I
thought I was on to something but then
it kind of mutated into something well
then you come crazy and kidnap people
and kidnapped the guy and I didn't mind
that I just felt that I had lost my
kinship with the writer or the
showrunner I felt like I had lost her
like she didn't want to talk to you
anymore
like she wasn't interested in me yeah
she's like yeah yeah I got it do that I
felt like that but that happens sure
you're passionate about something and
then all of a sudden you but but it's
also you know it can happen for me
you've been on series before it can
happen for a million reasons and and by
the way that's not in any way a put-down
not at all not in any way I just
well it didn't get picked up so
insatiable didn't get picked up yeah I
thought I know I thought the two seasons
two seasons but I haven't heard about
the third one I should say too hasn't
been picked up yet
my friend Sarah Colonna works on that
you don't know her you never worked with
her but she said she thinks you're great
I think she's great
I texted her I said yeah many goods on
my girl bath here oh what'd she say she
said she's fantastic
it's call her let's call her I love her
Sarah what are you gonna say I'm gonna
say hey it'll be odd she did a few apps
she plays a pageant coach but the show
is dark and crated she's crazy in it she
kidnaps the main character blah blah
blah she's super fun in it no super fun
in it well just tell her you're sitting
with me and I love her in it and and I'd
love to meet her sometime for real I met
her once in that makeup job
really mm-hmm yeah she's a sweetheart I
mean obviously you're are you close with
your kids kids kids it extremely close
but they're we're wondering this is a
rare thing because there's a lot of time
in your life when you and Al weren't
close and now you kind of like get along
with this girl and Wonder
he broke up with her but yo it's it's
all know we have a spectacular
friendship in fact I take him more of my
eye I tell him everything does he live
in town yeah yeah I tell him everything
I don't know if he tells me everything
but you know does he call you yeah we
talk all the time yes but that's that
that's different the last couple years
right no no no no not this has been
going on for a few years but before that
it was no talk right no it was always
talk but you know we kind of went from
yuksom
loving each other becoming parents
hating each other becoming friends and
then best friend and now you're back in
the best friends did he call you like
little things like you know Bev I don't
know it's Carl as you start talking
about her I got to tell you something
you know I've known now 24 years and if
you've noticed I'm I may be the only
person who's never discussed my
relationship with them and I won't now
it's really private
really I've told you a lot yeah but I
like that your point is I like that
you're you guys get along we do rarity I
don't think it's a rarity but it's also
me I've got that wiring I am designed to
to have long-term relationships I always
view even intimate relationships I
always view them as like there are two
tracks there's like you can have a
profound friendship because of the
intimacy that you've incurred and
wanting to share these feelings and and
or you can have and there's the sexual
track but but my feeling is that if the
sexual track interferes with that
profound friendship it's kind of a waste
of time who are your the professional
friends in light that you've worked with
that you've remained close close friends
name one everybody
Chetty is heavy probably your closest in
terms of uh longest longest but I like
that I think that you're you're a
likable person you've always been like
you know what I'd like to be like
harmonious atmosphere
hey you you always talk about you
remember Carrie used to have all these
big parties at her house these
gatherings even if it was ten of us or
whatever it was just fun it felt like
any you know it's a cheers everybody
I only just stopped entertaining but
yeah because you would have some of
these things you start to get it going
and I think the
you should do it more often now that you
have to do it all the time I know we
need to get some of the game did Alan I
did all the holiday parties together
that was good but it was just you guys
right you and the kids and him well I've
expanded I know don't get mad at me
don't don't don't why you didn't invite
me I think I did you did say you didn't
I did invite you you did I couldn't make
anything yeah that's right yeah that's
right you read nosy but the next time I
talk to you I want to be talking about
you about to go do your one-woman show
but I don't want listen I don't want you
to you don't need to rush you're not it
doesn't have to be done tomorrow but I'm
so afraid I'll run out of juice you know
you're not gonna run out juice it's all
there it's in your head I've heard your
head I've heard the noise no it would go
a lot faster
you need a director you know what well
I've had two directors but actually what
I'm doing now is um you know I kind of
read I was a member of the Actors Studio
New York and now I'm doing classes here
you're taking acting classes I'm I'm in
the acting class I'm you know watching
um put a scene up but I'm also gonna
take the director's class really what
made you want to do that well it was
ours idea that I find a place to just
stay engaged while my musical guy is
gone and also because he knows what I'm
going through of like I got I got I got
I gotta get it going I gotta get I don't
know what I need do I need to get my
heart broken by this guy do I need to
work out for two hours until my muscles
are I mean like what do I need to do to
access the muse I need the muse I need
them you said a yeah and you know I do
things to access the muse but my
strongest one is find that unavailable
person and yearn and and an energy comes
out of it I'm not kidding I know I'm
[ __ ] up but this is life and I will
tell you one thing that originally you
know songs that were written were
written in the church and they were
written as aspirations to God and
romantic songs or lays came about when
there was a shift and the singers
stopped singing about I Love You God and
I you know come to me bring show me your
light
started singing that to a woman I love
you bring me you you know that's the
shift that happens I'm learning off in
the 1400s are you learning and so I even
think at times like okay this these
desires these these yearnings maybe it's
just I want the higher thing maybe I
just want to connect to the universe if
I could just get a direct shot from the
universe into my creative spirit I would
be happy but I seem to always have to go
through man do you go through do you say
do you see a therapist
no you don't go to therapy at all no no
do you think you need therapy no why is
that I did altered state therapy that's
kind of therapy Oh like altered state
yeah
and what is that with drugs at all had
to mean ketamine I did ketamine for pain
doesn't work for pain I didn't well they
said it would works for PTSD so you had
a lot of PTSD I didn't have a lot of
PTSD I had I had four specific things I
was going after and I and I worked with
though exactly they were I spoke with
him a few times to kind of nail down a I
went after it I mean the way that I did
it was not in a clinic it was uh it was
privately and it was it was immensely
helpful and when I say to you you know
oh I've you know I need to have a man I
I I'm not saying that to you as a
self-deprecating thing I'm saying that
as a woman who understands her machinery
I'm saying that as a woman who
understands her creative machinery I
became an actress because Milosz Foreman
said under leash cool you have to decide
if you will be a good girlfriend or a
good actress and I thought what does he
need more he needs someone to star in
his movie I can do that I I wanted to be
a singer and I was singing jazz and kind
of writing these plaintive little songs
in Canada and Ronnie Hawkins disbanded
just left him and gun on the road as the
with Dylan his hawks or whatever and he
said you know stick with me and I have
the apartment through so so I learned
all these rockabilly tunes it's always
been in service of some man
and I always get out of it carrying the
pearls but it just that's that's my
machinery and I'm kind of into it
although I have a flight thought is it
really am I just trying to get to that
Universal that universal consciousness
where all of our hopes and desires and
creativity lies to make some art but
here's what I think I know I sound like
evolution no I think some people will
think you're probably a little crazy and
some people think you're genius what's
so crazy no tell me I'm crazy and genius
there's a thin line I think what you're
saying makes perfect sense to me some
people think oh whatever
but why do I want to deal with those but
exactly that's my point but that was
mine what I'm thinking is this I know
where mine were my mind goes in millions
of places and I could feel like oh I'm
all over the place which I probably feel
in a lot of ways to open right
but then I sort of feel like you know
I'm my god you know I'm this and I'm
thinking of this I'm thinking of this
and how do I calm my mind down there is
that one thing I think it was Einstein
but that's why I go to therapy just
because I like to channel all this [ __ ]
for an hour and a half and then go I
feel good it's off my chest I'd do it in
a different way I write songs I work on
my you use it I use damage yeah I use it
see and I mean it's it's getting
frustrating because all the work that
I've been doing since last May I don't
have something to show for it so it does
sound crazy when I say I'm using it it
sounds crazy if I was just in a normal
life and I wasn't and I didn't have any
creative outlets like oh yeah maybe I
should do therapy but that's not where
I'm at but I think you know I'm not at
that I don't do that by the way if you
say you're crazy because in a year or
whatever you haven't figured out a
one-woman show that's the genius that
you've been thinking for your your for
how many years it takes time you know
what Rufus said he said I should just
book the kick and then I'll have to do
it you know what somebody else just told
me like they say I don't book the game
people always wake here's what he said
it's actually you know who this was this
is Billy Boyd from Lord of the Rings he
was on the last podcast or a podcast few
weeks ago and he says this made a lot of
sense
people are always sniffing accent hello
to the exit but he said people are
always wanting to perfect
something to rehearse it so much and
then before because they don't want
people to think or show it's that woman
that's radish and he goes that's just
part of it like oh well I know but
here's the thing that is my second phase
my second phase is in April when Kirk
comes back from their row with weasel
and we are gonna put it on its feet
there you go last question yeah has al
did you ever ask al I know [ __ ] about
the poster no nothing sexual nothing
I said poster oh oh yeah oh yeah you're
gonna get him in now he'll do that you
said he did no I'm gonna ask you about
this did you ever ask him to run Lions
or did he ever ask you run lines
I just think that'd be funny watching
you guys are in lines together I'm not
gonna indulge in this kind of
sycophantic fan-based
line of questioning it's really
demeaning and you you shouldn't do that
it's wait it's demeaning it's demeaning
yourself when someone cause it's a
fan-like thing that means they put
someone above them I don't if you put
someone above you you're putting some
minutes someone goes that she ever run
lines with you I go I'd say none of your
business
[ __ ] you beverly d'angelo we go out to
dinner with me again soon yeah this is
called [ __ ] talkin throws and BOM quick
questions answer quickly Benjamin J the
central is one of the nuttiest horror
movies ever made with lots of great
actors making brief appearances do you
have any stories from working on this
movie and being directed by Michael
Winner I have a great story and here's
what it is I'll make it breathe through
it I'm in New York I came to New York
from Canada with a Broadway show it
opened it closed
lots of casting directors dug me it was
a musical version of Hamlet I get called
in to meet with Michael Winner who was
doing his next film after death wish I
go into the meeting he says to me he
talks to me for a few minutes and he
says I want you to take this script home
and read for the read the role of Sandra
because I'm offering it to you I'd never
been in the movies I wasn't in Screen
Actors Guild I go home I read it I
called the casting director and said I
need to come back down and meet Michael
winners of Vesperia unusual you need
your agent to arrange that and I said no
no no I don't have an agent but I need
to talk to me offered me the role what
she comes back on the phone two minutes
later and says Michael will see you I go
down there and I said okay Michael look
I'm a singer I'm not an actress but if I
wanted to be an actress
think I really want to do this movie and
because my dear I've done death wish I'd
worked with Milan Brennan of course you
want to do this movie starring Ava
Gardner burgess Meredith all the greats
I said but look look look on page 60 I'm
eating the brains out of a guy's head
and and I'm a zombie or something he
said but my dear you'll be eating the
brains out of Chris Sarandon said and
he's just been nominated for a dog an
Oscar for Dog Day Afternoon and I said
well okay but look at this look at this
look at this
I'm page page 60 or you know whatever
page it was I I'm gonna I've got a
masturbation scene and I'm part of a
lesbian couple and he got a mute part of
a lesbian couple in his but my dear yo
lesbian lover will be played by Sylvia
miles and she's been nominated twice so
I thought okay so you did it yeah all
right Andrew see any great memories
working on Annie Hall back in 77 I again
same thing Broadway show closed I had
done the Sentinel at this point I still
didn't have a Screen Actors Guild card
casting director called me in to meet
Woody Allen I had just happened to have
a dream about him the night before I
took in my my diary I said look I just
dreamt that you were in my backyard in
the snow playing the tuba and he said
duck I'm working on a film can you come
and be in it tomorrow I said yeah and
that's how I ended up in Annie Hall ROG
any interesting stories from working on
The Simpsons
oh well Dave merkins long time Dave
merkins one of my true friends to this
day and it was always fabulous and I
wrote finally bagged me a Homer for that
show and have the publishing and it's
made me very very happy
Janell s Christmas vacations very
special place in so many hearts what are
your favorite memories are just a memory
from the set that you remember like I
remember that we're just engine I
remembered that they were so rushed when
we were getting this group shot that I
said to Chevie I'm gonna put my hand on
your crotch and like that they bet the
director won't catch it and it was true
and there's there's a shot in there
because we only had one time oh yeah
yeah it was like he goes freeze and
that's the one that you it is because it
was the only one we had to get it and I
said that that directors never gonna
notice what I'm doing because he'd never
did Lisa which version of the Griswold
kids do you feel most embodied the
spirit of the Griswolds I'm very partial
to the first vacation because it was so
innocent and so pure but they're all so
cool I just did a screening at the
Academy of Christmas vacation with
Juliette Lewis and Johnny Galecki and
they're just you know cooking on all
four burners they're all great
Brittany G how'd it feel getting called
in to come into a vacation movie in 2015
did it bring back memories starring with
Chevy again well Chevie and I had just
finished doing we there had just
finished oh no we were just on our way
to doing a pilot together so it was just
a reunion of sorts Nikko P if you could
go back and we choose acting or music as
a career path which would you choose
I would I had an Albert for album deal
and I didn't do it I would have if I
could go back I would have said Beverly
just keep pushing stay true to yourself
don't don't don't give up just because
they all want disco Karen B Beverly what
was it like growing up with just
brothers being the only girl well I
think it affected me in the way that I I
relate to men as brothers and that's not
sexy and but that's what Michael and I
have been talking about because if you
had to boil me down wouldn't you say I'm
a sister type sister don't pressure is a
sister I'm not mysterious I'm friendly
well I mean I've known you for so long
but if I if I was a dude that was like
you know didn't know yeah Billy
kind of sexy she's funny she's
ridiculous you let ik like I think oh
yeah throw a ball to be sexy no no no to
be a true sister no but but here's what
I do know my best girlfriends except for
two of them are dead hmm
so my world is populated by all men and
it's very comfortable I love men I love
to be around then I love the way they
think I love the way they can
compartmentalize they inspire me I live
for them just don't attack them just I
know last Angie can you share one thing
you miss the most about the late great
Carrie Fisher and sidenote also I have
to say that after your Don Henley's
story the last episode I decided you are
my spirit animal
so one story that we don't know about
care that you just remember that you
just
at a small moment oh god it's a 34 years
in so many moments
oh oh oh you've caught me off balance
moment that was just you and her a
million of them I know just lying on our
bed Bailey enough watching old movies a
million of them I can't I'll tell you a
moment
my son was dying and he was triaged into
Columbia Presbyterian New York I was in
Alaska my son was eight weeks old and I
was film and I didn't know what to do
and I called Carrie and it was about
1:00 in the afternoon and Carrie was
there by midnight with a pillow and a
blanket and she stayed with me until my
son was okay three days later there's a
moment for you and she just went come on
let's go shopping in the gift shop no I
don't want to put the baby down Beth
come on you know but uh that's a set oh
I went to the sad no that's good you
would get friendship because you always
hear these funny stories about I will
tell you this that that weekend that we
met the the hysteria the myriad of hot
springs we drove home together I'd taken
a limo down there we drove home together
and we stopped at a place and got our
hair crimped in the same hairstyle they
were like these crimping Islands and we
had like really weird hair that was fun
how old were you when I met Carrie twins
[Music]
all right I love this this is great okay
I love you
I love listening to that lady she's
she's out there isn't she she's
wonderful and brilliant all that stuff
beverly d'angelo thank you again for
listening I hope you enjoyed it always
tweet us and Instagram us or hello at
inside a podcast calm and you could you
know ask me questions write in letters I
love the letters that you send and we'll
read one but first lets me let's give a
shout out to the top tiers of patron
patreon all right here we go Nancy D
Mary B Lea ass Trisha app Sarah V Yukiko
Jill O'Brien H Lauren Jeannie kopi Barry
I a big shout-out to Niko P for helping
with my neck got some Botox injections
in the back of my neck
they said it's good for you or they
could help you and we'll see what
happens
Barry I Angelina G Jerry W Kevin R Emily
K Bob the Robert B Bork Tax Board eggs
Jason W Tiana D Andrew see Alison L mark
a Jason D Chris ROG Siraj IRA you have a
lot of toys Sean W Joshua D Emily s hi
Emily see JP rocks raccoon Samantha M
Hamza be Stacey be Carly t Vanessa in
the sky green Jennifer s Jenelle be neil
w tabitha 272 kimberly e Melissa are
Mikey Jake M Catherine am Jack asked
Carly asked Jude @d r Amira love that
name if I said it right tell me if I
didn't on patron I'll respond Chris F
CeraVe Sean W Stacey be Tabitha 272
Tiana D Trisha F Vanessa in the sky
Yukiko if you heard your name twice
I think Bryce put your name twice on
there and maybe he did maybe he didn't
but I might have screwed it up it's easy
for me to do that these days when I'm
doing everything here in the studio uh
you know I just hope this is in focus I
hope the sounds working well let's read
a letter
ah ok this is uh this is from Kate I've
been listening to the podcast and I wish
I had found it sooner
as much as my nerd heart enjoys it for
the content and great guests the heart
is we keep springing me back it helps to
know that there are other broken
children out there that are still trying
to figure [ __ ] out well into adulthood
amen
Kate my mother is dying and I'm when I
went to see her a few months ago for the
first time in years I left knowing it
would be the last time I saw her
I also know that I left without real
closure
solution
that she would die unchanged and without
any remorse for what she did to her
children I'm never gonna get I'm never
going to get what I needed from her it
is what it is I feel like this is a
theme in the podcast and I appreciate
the frankness of it I'm still working
through how I feel about her and I never
really feel the need to talk about it
but listening to the show on my drive
home is therapeutic knowing there are
kindred spirits out there lightens the
burden and allows me to give myself some
grace and extend it to those around me I
hope it does the same for you
keep pushing out episodes and I will
keep listening Kate
Kate
you sent this not exactly sure when you
sent this but it was months ago and
sometimes they don't get around to them
but first of all I'm sorry about your
your mom and I'm sorry you didn't get
closure but you know that I think an
important part of all this is knowing
the truth and only you
you know the truth
how you feel about her
is how you feel about her
and you know sometimes you can't make
excuses for people you can't say oh well
this and this forgiving is is important
knowing the truth is important I'm not a
therapist but I've gone to enough
therapy to kind of sort of sort of
understand it so Kate thanks for your
letter it's brave and and I really
appreciate you listening I'm and I'm
more so I'm glad you get something out
of the show I really am I really I
really think that's uh you know that's
good that's all I can say uh I was heavy
I hope you guys enjoyed the show we had
a lot of great episodes coming I know
sometimes you probably like you know
it's hard because you know people are
always looking for the biggest and best
guests and you know sometimes our guests
or bigger stars and the ones that are
you know I love all my guests and
they're all fantastic and whether you
like them or not I hope that you'll
listen because you like to learn about
human nature and humanity in general and
what makes people tick and you'd like to
learn and I think that's that's the most
important thing so thank you for
listening please follow all our handles
inside a podcast or inside a pod on
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook I'm
on the patreon if you want to pledge and
see a bunch of behind the
what-do-you-call-it behind the scenes
sort of we do extra I did a bonus with
Harlan Williams my good buddy comedian
we did a video I interviewed him for
like a little 20 minute fun thing just
for patrons and I do it inside of you
inside of me where I film myself and
answer questions the patrons I do so
it's a lot of fun I love to continue
support there's different tiers and
stuff check that out I'm on the Cameo
thanks for supporting left on Laurel the
band I've been writing some more songs
maybe I'll share one with you well these
times I'll see on the YouTube live or
the Instagram live that we just urge you
to
it's hard but just try to appreciate
what you have in front of you you know I
I'm telling you that as I'm you know I'm
working on that but the more you you say
I'm grateful for this and this and you
start thinking it's amazing how the
brain works I've talked about that so
let's just try to be better people you
know that's all we could do thank you
again for everything and we'll get
through this together
thank you for longed to be inside of
each and every one of you and much love
to you and shout out to my friend Ethan
avoner who loves the fan letters I
appreciate him telling you that
[Music]